i'm here today with ben shapiro ben and
i met
about eight months ago and he came up to
toronto and gave a rousing talk
and uh uh
to talk about political correctness at
that point quite a politically pointed
political talk and i got a couple of
questions for you one is what would what
what are you planning to do in 2018 what
do you want to see happen in 2018
personally and
and what like so what are you aiming at
and why
so i mean obviously i'm aiming at
broadening the the reach of the the
political messages that i espouse and
the messages of i think personal
responsibility and virtue that i tried
to espouse i'm also working on a book
that i'm really interested in right now
about the roots of western civilization
what is that makes for a happier and
more fulfilled western civilization what
generates purpose for civilization and
for individuals and why it is that we
seem to have lost purpose because my
general theory is that the reason that
we're trying to murder each other
politically and the reason that we hate
each other so much is that there is a
purpose-shaped hole in our heart that we
are now filling with anger tribal anger
at each other uh and i'm trying to trace
back kind of backtrack and say okay
where did where did we go wrong where
where was purpose it's sort of it's it's
high water mark and why are we now at
low ebb
okay
one of the things that i found in the
discussions that i've had over the last
year especially the the public
discussions public lectures let's say is
that
it seems
perfectly
possible to make a room go silent by
speaking to especially if it's a room
full of young men by speaking to them
about responsibility and truth
and this has really staggered me because
those are not obviously saleable
messages
you know especially for someone who's
rather cynical about the fundamental
nature of human beings i'm not saying
that i am but
if you if you launched a business plan
to the typical observers and said well
i'm going to
base a
public movement on
the adoption of excess responsibility
and the requirement to speak the truth
and that's going to become hyper popular
the probability that people would agree
that that's a possibility is pretty much
zero
and so i've been thinking that
we've spoken about rights for so long
and spoken about freedoms for so long
let's say since the early 60s
just essentially speaking that we've
actually left a conceptual hole in our
culture
and that seems to be akin to
to the point that you're making with
regards to this book and now you you you
mentioned responsibility and why that
specifically
well i think that
what you're talking about is exactly
right people in in the west have seemed
to pose rights in
in direct opposition to duties so the
american founding particularly was
obsessed with this idea of of rights and
individual rights but there was also
this corresponding idea of duties that's
very clear in founding thinking george
washington talks about duty benjamin
franklin talks about duty the idea was
that duty was to be socially generated
not by government but by society itself
by small communities by churches by your
family and that that would fill the gap
that allowed you to actually have a
functioning society of rights but we
seem to have left duty completely behind
now it's just all about the rights and
not about the duty and what's happened
is that that's collapsed in on itself
because a society of only rights and no
duties ends up generating
generating duties masquerading as rights
right positive rights that are actually
not rights at all that are me imposing a
duty on you in order to further my own
perception of my rights and that's i
think where we've been going and it's
it's a dark place and it creates an
enormous amount of opposition when you
say jordan when you when you talk about
the fact that people would not have
thought of building a movement on
notions of truth and responsibility
that's because i think for a long time
people just took it for granted we all
agreed on these things um but there's
been an actual forcible counter movement
for generations now against both truth
and responsibility the idea is there's
no objective truth it's socially defined
we can make it up as we go along there's
no telos right i talk a lot in the new
book about about the teleological way of
thinking this idea that you actually
have a purpose for which you were
created
and that it's your job to fulfill that
purpose and that's completely been left
by the wayside so there's no truth
there's no capacity even right the
scientific materialist worldview
actually robs you of the capacity to
even change yourself right the studies
that i've seen suggest that if you
believe in a certain form of determinism
if you believe in hard determinism
you're less likely to go out and
actually change your life and make it
better because you buy into your own
philosophy and i think that as a society
we've sort of bought into that that
we're all victims of our own biology
victims of our own race victims our own
ethnicity or our situation and there's
no way for us to get out of that so we
may as well throw up our hands or at
least give the power to the only thing
that can change things is this which is
this massive collective that comes in
and is the boot stomping on the human
face forever
well there's also the strange
misapprehension i think with regards to
the nature of rights because
as far as i can tell i mean rights have
rights are a multi-faceted phenomena but
i think
the least
metaphysical claim that you can make
about rights is that if i have a right
then that brings with it a parallel
responsibility not only to myself to to
act in a manner that is in accordance
with that right whatever that happens to
be but i also have a responsibility if
the right is universal to act in a
certain manner towards you and so
because what there is no difference
between rights and responsibilities
fundamentally they're just the mirror
image of one another now that that's to
say nothing about their potential
metaphysical origin and i don't want to
talk about that but
it doesn't seem to me to be logically
terrible to have an infinite
conversation about rights without having
a parallel conversation about
responsibility so there's a logical flaw
in it that leaves that gap that needs to
be filled and then the other thing
that's occurred to me
is that
that the genuine meaning in life and i
do believe that life has a genuine
meaning i i think i could make that
claim without even making it
metaphysical although i don't mind the
metaphysical
addition to it
it seems to me that almost all the
things that people find meaningful in
life that aren't merely impulsive
pleasures which of course create their
own entanglements have to do with the
voluntary adoption of responsibility
so families like that
okay so all right so then
okay so here's here's the next question
what do you think it is that's driven
our loss of of that
half of the conversation what's happened
so i think that this has been basically
a 200-year movement that first
manifested itself in europe and is
finally reaching american shores about
100 years later which seems to be the
pattern all the bad stuff from europe
hits europe about 50 to 100 years before
it hits here and now comes here i think
that what happened here is that the
enlightenment mentality was built on
certain fundamental premises including
the use of human reason the capacity for
free will
and all of that in turn rested on
assumptions about the universe including
the idea that the universe has a
discoverable design that we can actually
find and pursue and that in doing so we
will find happiness the aristotelian
idea of happiness is very much bound up
with the idea of you fulfilling your
telos the judeo-christian idea of
happiness is you fulfilling god's
purpose for you there's always this idea
of a higher purpose that you were
seeking and i think what happened is
that the the the enlightenment project
which started off in an attempt really
in the 13th century by people like
aquinas and maimonides to unite religion
and science fell apart when they started
to divide the two instead of it's we're
seeking the same thing religion and
science are both seeking a universal
truth that can be applicable to our own
lives and make us more fulfilled the
project of science became to destroy
one pole to destroy religion and then by
doing that science almost turned in on
itself reason almost ate itself so i
think reason basically turned into okay
we're going to follow to the logical end
point all of the all of the
non-religious bases of of human thought
and once you do that it's very difficult
not to fall into
a subtle
a sort of self-refuting trap about human
thought you're just a set of neurons
that are firing neurons don't have
responsibility your dog doesn't have
responsibility do you have
responsibility uh you are a product of
your environment your biology does that
carry with it any sort of moral
responsibility you don't have the
capacity to choose if you don't have the
capacity to choose how do you have moral
responsibility i debated sam harris on
particularly this issue and i thought
that actually the most telling point of
the the debate and discussion was not
anything the two of us said it was a
woman who got up at the very end and
said to sam i totally agree with you
there's no free will in the hard sense
you can't make any so you there's no
choice other than to right you will have
to do this just driven by your biology
and environment
but i have a five-year-old son what do
you want and what should i say to him
and sam basically said lie right
basically well tell him that he's
capable of making a choice and that
that's the truth about civilization
either you believe that's a lie and
you're actively engaging in plato's good
lie basically um or you're or you have
to believe in free will and i don't
think i don't think the capacity to
choose in the capacity to self better
is is a lie i think that people do have
the capacity to do that i think even sam
believes that but he refuses to
acknowledge it because otherwise i don't
think he would be in the educational
position that he is right he spends his
life trying to educate people so that
it's all weird i mean i actually said in
the in the discussion why are we all in
this auditorium we were just sort of
predestined by the universe to be in
this auditorium at a certain time like
do you feel fulfilled by that if so you
really have no choice in the matter
well one of the things that's always
bothered me about the new atheist types
and the hyper rationalists is that
they're as far as i can tell their
conduct is full of performative
contradictions they say they believe
certain things but they don't act that
way
and in my sense because i'm an
existentialist at heart is that what you
believe is what you act out what you say
might be in accordance with that and it
might not but but
and there's no reason to assume that
your beliefs are transparent to yourself
regardless of your claims
and so
i also don't see any evidence whatsoever
that a society can exist that functions
over any reasonable
period of time in any reasonable manner
without
predicating itself on the belief that
people are both capable of free will and
that they're responsible
and so the fact that it seems to be
impossible to build a functioning
society
or even functioning dyadic relationships
for that matter in the absence of the
presupposition of free will and the
capacity for voluntary change indicates
to me
some evidence for the existence of those
capacities and you have to be a
staggeringly cynical person to think
that no we just have to believe that
that's true even though it's a lie and
predicate our cultures on that i mean
that's first of all i don't
i think it's a weak claim i don't think
that it's it's also not the the rock
upon which you want to found your
culture
so
one of the things that struck me about
the mythological stories that i've
immersed myself in is that there's
always three there's always three prime
characters in a mythological story
there's culture right so that's the
great father let's say and there's many
mythological guises and there's nature
that's the great mother and so you could
say that that's the
biology and society of of the modern
scientists but then there's the
independent individual as a causal force
who has a nature that enables enables
choice and free will and all of those
things and that that independent third
factor is something like the logos that
gives rise to being at the beginning of
time right the cast that calls order
forth out of chaos and and the fact that
we can't account for that scientifically
although i don't think we can deny it
either doesn't mean that it doesn't
exist
yeah i totally agree with that and of
course i enjoy maps of meaning so i'm
pretty familiar with the terminology
that you use uh because i've read your
book but i think that you know there's
this idea that you can find meaning in a
meaningless universe that we're just
meatballs wandering through space with a
little bit of sentience understanding
that we're our meatballs wandering
through space i have a hard time
building any sort of system on that and
the refusal of the new atheists to even
recognize that the morality that they
promulgate right the rip that they have
on religion typically is that religion
is barbaric and backwards and
promulgates all sorts of horrible moral
values that with which they disagree
and what they refuse to acknowledge that
their moral values are predicated within
that system right for the vast majority
of human time the values that they are
espousing are not not only not universal
they're not even minority values they
didn't exist for the vast majority of
human time
they are absolute creations of a
judeo-christian system that is combined
with a greek reason to come up with what
we have today and this is essentially
the theory that i have come up with is
that and this is the thesis of the book
that i'm writing right now which is that
in order for in in order for a society
or an individual to feel fulfilled you
basically have to have four things you
have to have an individual purpose you
have to feel like you have a purpose in
the world you personally have a purpose
in the world you have to feel like you
have an individual capacity you have to
feel like you are capable of pursuing
that with alacrity you have to have a
communal purpose you have to feel like
you along with others are pursuing a
higher goal that means something and you
have to have communal capacity so a
system that has been built that allows
that community to activate when it needs
to activate and back off so that the
individual can exist in that vacuum
and and we have torn away at all the
roots of those things because all of
those things that i think the apotheosis
of the i think the apex of of modern
thought was basically the unfulfilled
but universal theories of the the
american founding fathers i think is
about as good as it got in terms of
governmental theory i don't think it's
gotten better since then i think that
it's been extended more broadly i think
the universalism that they were implying
has now been applied in many ways and
that's a great thing right the founders
obviously
still held slaves many of them but their
their principles were not in favor of
slavery uh so the principles that they
espoused were based on again these two
competing polls that are they're
constantly in tension with one another
in this sort of leo straussi intention
with one another between reason and
revelation the the judeo-christian
tradition and the greek tradition of
reason and the tug and back and forth is
what allows you to have one foot in
right and one foot in duties
so it'd be really good to have a lengthy
conversation about this at some point
because there are some things in here
that really have to be delved in deeply
like the the
you have to find your own purpose
argument was one that was put forth very
strongly by nietzsche when after he
announced the death of god he said that
people would have to revalue good and
evil and to come up with their own
definitions of what constituted morality
and like the nietzschean criticism of of
christianity is about as deep as it got
with the possible exception of
dostoyevsky
but there's one of the things i really
liked about carl jung and that's really
struck me as
as is irrefutable is
jung's fundamental response to nietzsche
was that well
um
let's take the argument of the death of
god to its logical conclusion and then
let's investigate the idea that human
beings have to be the creator of the
creators of their own systems of meaning
jung's idea and this was also the case
for the other psychoanalysts was that's
just palpably false
because it turns out that you're not the
sort of creature that can
create your own meaning you're the sort
of creature that has to discover the
meaning that already exists encoded
within you and part of that is that
you're not your own slave
and and so so it's a critique not only
of the idea that you can will your own
destiny in its entirety while completely
ignoring the fact that you have a nature
but it's also a profound critique of the
socialist utopian ideas that human
beings can be molded in any way that
they see fit and so jung's objection was
something like
well try to generate a meaning on your
own out of nothing and then try to force
yourself to follow it and see how far
you get what you'll find is that you
rebel your own nature rebels in every
possible way against the arbitrary
imposition of a certain of just any old
moral framework on the manner in which
you're going to conduct yourself and so
yeah i think this is it's such a it's
such a deep critique and i think that
it's it's so telling because what we've
come up with is
the the substitute for what you're
talking about which is this
acknowledgement that there is a
universal purpose that we ought to be
aspiring to discover that it's actually
out there there's a purpose out there
and it's our job to uncover it as
opposed to self-creating it then that is
a really deep divide in in america i
think in the west generally because what
people have said is okay we finally
realized that we do need this thing
called purpose right we can't just be
hedonists all the time drugs and sex
aren't going to cut it and we're
actually going to need to
come up with some purpose because
they're hydras
right but we're not going to be able to
but but at the same time we don't want a
government or a society or a church or a
community forcing down its universal
perception of values on us and so
therefore our happy medium is going to
be you define your own your own freedom
you define your own your own rights and
you define your own view of the universe
well that is
always going to just devolve into this
pathetic sort of solipsism that that can
never be escaped from and doesn't
provide happiness anyway i mean the
people who quote unquote define their
own meaning are some of the least happy
people that you will ever meet because
they don't believe that they're in
consonance with anything larger if
you're if you're looking into yourself
yourself is not that big there's not
that much there right there has to be
something beyond you whether you find it
in god or whether you find it in a
community or in nature there has to be
something that speaks to you beyond the
guts that exist inside you or you're
just examining your own intestines
i think too that you can make a strong
scientific case this is something i
never got to in my discussions with sam
harris is you can make a strong
scientific case for the reality of
meaning as an as a
for let's just call it for the reality
of meaning you might think about it as a
psychological reality but you can think
about it as a metaphysical or a
biological reality too because as far as
i can tell
and and there's good neurological
evidence for this your brain is adapted
to two modes of being and one mode of
being is that mode that obtains when
you're where you know what you're doing
and you know what's going on so you
could call that explored territory let's
say and there's another
motive being that is that which obtains
in when you don't know what's going on
when you're in unexplored territory you
can say well animals since the beginning
of time have adapted to some combination
of explored and unexplored territory and
that's roughly akin to known and unknown
which i think is what's symbolized in
the yin yang symbol and as far as i can
tell
the sense of meaning that people
experience that's spontaneous and deep
is an indication that they're
functioning well in explored territory
but simultaneously increasing their
capacity to deal with unexplored
territory so it's it's like the zone of
proximal development or even the flow
states that chick said mahali has talked
about but see the best thing to be
is where things are going well for you
but also where you're expanding the
capacity of things to go well for you
simultaneously and then you can add to
that the fact that that's not going to
be solipsistic because we live in a
social world if i'm pursuing something
that's deeply meaningful then what if if
things are constructed fortunately then
i'm going to be pursuing something
that's very good for me
now
and me later and me deep into the future
at the same time i'm pursuing something
that's good for you now and you later
and you deep into the future and i
believe that that sense of of deep
engagement that envelopes people in
fortunate periods of their lives is
actually a neurological signal that
that the layers of being are stacked
on top of one another properly and that
you're oriented
properly within them and then it's the
it's i see to me
i've i've often thought that the most
real thing is pain
and then you might say well
if there's an antidote to pain that
would be something that would be even
more real than pain and it seems to me
that the sense of meaning that i'm
talking about here that's associated
with this with this sense of ultimate
responsibility is an antidote to pain
and therefore is something that's most
real i don't see anything you can make a
metaphysical claim about that and that's
perfectly reasonable but you don't have
to you can make a bloody hardcore
scientific claim for that and i think
it's extremely difficult to refute
why wouldn't we have
i tend to agree with that and i think
that you know you you're referencing the
flow state that's something that
where we are happiest right from
scientific research is in that flow
state and that flow state is exactly
what we're talking about now this this
feeling that you have mastery over your
capacity to explore the unexplored and
that the unexplored is worth is worth
exploring right i mean that's the other
thing is that
what drives you to to explore the
unexplored it's not just that you get up
in the morning and you feel like
wandering outside into the forest
there's some of that but i think some of
it is that you feel like there's an
actual necessity for you as a human
being to do that there's a moral duty
for you to try and conquer new worlds
and adding the moral layer more the
moral impetus on top of i just have a
decision to to to go out and explore
unexplored territory is what i think
allows civilization to to create rather
than destroy and i've talked a lot on my
show about like male male toxicity you
know what people have to the toxic
masculinity and all this yeah yeah and
and
what and the binary nature i think of
human beings particularly men
is that men because i have a little boy
who's a year and a half old and he's
either he's either building a stack of
blocks or he's destroying the stack of
blocks there is no in-between and so if
you are if you're exploring unexplored
territory there are only two ways to
deal with that one is to actually take a
fire and set it in the unexplored
territory or the other is to cultivate
that unexplored territory and adding
that moral layer of it's your job to
forge out into the universe and make
that cultivated territory to bring that
into the known
that adding that moral dimension is i
think
what both the greeks and judeo-christian
tradition are about now i think it's
more than judeo-christian but the idea
that there is a god worth exploring and
that god has reached down to man and
uplifted him is is i think relevant to
jail christian religion and is really
the essence of judeo-christian religion
if you look at polytheism
that notion that you're out there to try
and understand god it doesn't it doesn't
exist in polytheistic religion the
notion that you're supposed to look
beyond your you're supposed to look
beyond yourself to a broader
understanding of the universe no you're
subject to forces in the universe right
and those were represented by the
different gods not this idea that
there's a universal system that's that's
at least partially knowable that if you
spend your life trying to investigate
and live in consonance with you will be
happier that's a lot closer to the greek
system which is why you end up with this
common idea of the logos that you talk
about being in the book of john but also
really springing from from greek thought
i mean that's that's that's the idea
there right right right right yes it's
an unbelievably brilliant synthesis now
you you touched on the idea of
cultivation so i wanted to ask you about
that i'm going to amsterdam to talk to
this event at this event sponsored by a
group called the dutch lion and that's
going to happen december uh january 19th
and we've got about 2 000 people
attending this event and it's going to
be a national discussion about
uh dutch and european identity and
immigration and so in principle it could
be a big deal and one of the things i've
been meditating on is what it is that
western civilization got right
and so the first thing i think is that
we got the idea of the logos right
that's a big deal the sovereignty of the
individual and the sovereignty and the
necessity for respect of the capacity of
the
exploring individual to conquer new
territory and make it habitable we got
that right and so and i mean
fundamentally right but then
that seems also to me to tie
interestingly into the idea of property
rights because the fundamental marxist
claim there's a number of them but one
of the most fundamental claims is that
property is in some sense theft and so
that might even mean the property that
you accrued as a consequence of being
successful and i think it might be worth
giving the devil is due and say well
are there conditions under which my
occupation of a space to the exclusion
of you isn't merely theft and the idea
of cultivation i think is exactly the
right answer to that is that
the point is for
each of us to allow
the other to occupy a particular place
and time in the hopes that we'll each
take care of it for our own benefit and
for the benefit of others and then what
happens is that everyone wins
yeah and this is a very obviously
lock-in idea right this is this is
lock's idea of what makes property
worthwhile and property rights
worthwhile is you mixed your labor with
the land and you cultivated it which is
why locke specifically talks about the
notion of adverse possession right if i
own a piece of property and i just
decided to leave it trashed somewhere
and then someone comes in and cultivates
the property even though i own the
property i should have a good legal case
to actually make against that owner
because i'm not cultivating the property
the idea being that cultivation and use
of the land is actually your individual
duty it's your individual duty it's also
your communal duty so yeah i think that
the moral legitimacy of property rights
uh is you know in in lock's thought
particularly is very much tied to
cultivation and your personal stake in
what you've done with with the property
that you own again it's exactly your
point that there's a mix of rights and
duties property rights are linked to
duties it's not just property that you
own
okay so maybe we can close with this you
know the the idea of a garden is very
interesting to me and of course the
natural environment of the human being
is the garden according to genesis right
it's the garden of eden and i've thought
for a long time well why is it a garden
and the answer to that is that a garden
is the optimal
juxtaposition of nature and culture
right so a garden is nature
blooming of its own accord but tended
very carefully and so then the rule
would be something like you're allowed
you're allowed to own something
you have the right to own something you
have the privilege to own something if
what you're doing is transforming it
into a bountiful garden
that's exactly right i think that's true
and i think that's true in every area of
a successful life it's true with how you
raise your children you lose the right
to raise your children properly if
you're raising your children improperly
i think it's true of marriage marriages
break down when you don't cultivate
cultivation is the the ultimate human
need is cultivation and when we
cultivate whether it's in the realm of
knowledge or science or whether it's in
the realm of religion and relationships
then we are happier and when we don't
cultivate and we and when we deprive
ourselves of the capacity and both the
capacity and the purpose of cultivation
then everything falls into anarchy then
then just through entropy everything
will fall apart i think okay okay so the
right objection to privilege is
cultivation it's like i'm not privileged
i'm cultivating
i like that i like that a lot yeah well
it's necessary to get to grip these
things by the neck you know and so okay
that's good well look thanks very much
for talking to me i hope we get a chance
to talk again in the relatively near
future because there's some things we
could really sort out i think that'd be
great i'd really appreciate it i'm big
fan of jolly work obviously
yeah it's phoenix mutual thanks so much
good talking to you happy new year ray
you too
cheers
bye bye